these stars were serving up tea and hot
takes in 2021 welcome to entertainment
tonight everybody let's start with will
smith what a year it has been for him
king richard was fantastic yes it was
and his book but he put it all out there
starting with his open marriage to jada
in an emotional conversation with oprah
what does it mean to love in freedom the
simple idea is
it's friendship
versus marital prison
does that mean you all can have
other partners but you just have to be
respectful with each other
so people only think in terms of sex
people are trying to put something on it
will and jada they what they what they
doing with other people yeah right will
and jaden ain't really doing too much or
nothing
the goal is
not a sexual goal we're gonna love each
other no matter what
will gets right to the heart of their
non-traditional marriage during the
oprah conversation will smith streaming
now on apple tv plus the couple first
revealed details last year on red table
talk which coined a new term i got into
a different kind of entanglement an
entanglement yes
yes a relationship yes was that hard for
you sitting there
no no how long were you all actually
separated was it months or years we
never
actually like
officially separated we agreed that she
had to make herself happy
and i had to make
myself happy and then we were going to
present ourselves back to the
relationship we ride together we got
together
bad marriage for life
it's a far cry from the start of their
relationship in his memoir titled will
out now he writes quote we drank every
day and had sex multiple times every day
for four straight months
those early days were spectacular it
turned it ended up being a lot more
complex than that
jada and their kids jaden and willow
came out to support will at the king
richard premiere now i didn't mind you
saying we hard on these kids you know
why cause we are will who's getting
oscar buzz for his role playing venus
and serena's father told me he related
to the sisters rise to fame there's so
many parallels where people told you
know so many times where it where you
were flat on your back sometimes yeah
for sure no matter what they faced they
faced it as a family and they kept
pushing it it's magnificent can i just
applaud will smith for the year he has
had i mean you've been phenomenal um by
the way did oprah just talk to everybody
in
even me yeah that's a good point sure
did yeah but it was her one night only
sit down with adele where lady oh got
her to open up about something we all
wanted to hear about
[Applause]
[Music]
my body has been objectified my entire
career i was too big and i were too
small and when you were heavier you were
fine i was and i was body positive then
and i'm body positive now but it's not
my job to validate how people feel about
their bodies
i'm trying to sort my own life out i had
no time to choose
once i realized that i had a lot of work
to do on myself yeah i stopped drinking
and i started working out lots and stuff
like that to keep me sort of centered
adele got real about self-love during
her oprah sit down on cbs she also
talked about what inspired her to write
this song hold on how do i feel so
[Music]
i swear to god you say i'm such a mess
the harder that i try i regress
i am my own worst enemy
[Music]
the process of a divorce the process of
being a single parent the process of not
seeing your child every single day
wasn't really a plan that i had when i
you know when i had when i became a mum
and also trying to like move forward
with intention
from serious to the kind of silly adele
also covered a lot of ground reinventing
vogue 73 questions she answered 95.
spice girls are the beatles i mean
that's a bit unfair but i'm going to go
with spice girls
prince william or prince harry
prince
harry the video gave us a glimpse inside
the grammy winner's life as she unpacked
groceries in her kitchen and showed
vogue around her chic 10 million beverly
hills estate this is very english out
here what telly have you been binging
these days oh
ted lasso that's incredible have you
ever considered a different stage name
all this time no because my surname is
so boring is adkins
other highlights adele used a voice
changer app
and showed off her prized possession
it's pretty amazing
celine
dion's
gum
james corden who does carpool karaoke he
did it with her and knew how much a fan
of her i was and so he made her spit her
gum into piece of paper and he framed it
for me
but the most explosive oprah interview
was back in march when megan and harry
dropped this bomb
hold up there's a conversation
with you
with harry about how dark your baby is
going to be potentially and what that
would mean or look like
and you're not going to tell me who had
the conversation i think that would be
very damaging to them
in his new book brothers and wives
author christopher anderson claims to
know exactly who raised the question of
skin tone you talk about charles asking
camilla what he thinks the complexion
right of the baby will be right i was
able to trace back through a comment
that was made by charles to camilla over
breakfast the day their engagement was
announced
the palace denies that conversation took
place calling the claims quote fiction
my biggest concern was history repeating
itself when i'm talking about history
opinion itself i'm talking about my my
mother prince harry told oprah if it
wasn't for his mother the late princess
diana they wouldn't have even been able
to leave my family literally cut me off
financially and i had to wait hold up
wait a minute your family cut you off
yeah in the first half the first quarter
of 2020
but i've got what my mum left me and
without that we would not have been able
to do this
so now that harry and megan are no
longer working royals how are they
making money one way is through their
reported 100 million dollar multi-year
netflix deal yep the same network that
streams the crown i'm way more
comfortable with the crown
than i am seeing the stories written
about my family
harry's opened up since mexico swearing
rapping and visiting the fresh prince
house with james corden it's a different
side of the spare air who also admitted
this
we all know what the british press can
be like and it was destroying my mental
health i was like this is toxic
and in june harry became a girl dad as
he and megan welcomed their second child
lilibet last month megan gave ellen an
update on her latest milestones lily is
now teething so you're not you didn't
sleep last night i know that you're here
but of course you're not sleeping at all
well she's a good sleeper but the teeth
are coming in so anything to relieve
that tequila anything
i haven't tried that yet yep
i know that's auntie ellen for you
that's right
that's why i don't have kids
that's why ellen looks so well rested
because there are no parents on this
planet that are sleeping meanwhile the
sussex's good friends the clooneys had
their own confessions to make like the
moment george and them all decided they
wanted kids
we've been married for about a year and
the mall said we're awfully lucky in
life and she said it seems like that
luck should be shared with some other
you know folks and i thought about it
for i don't know maybe a minute then i
just said well i'm in if you're in and
she said i think we should try
that was the 60 year old father of twins
on mark marin's podcast clooney also
talked parenting to the guardian telling
the paper we have a nanny four days a
week and the rest of the time it's just
us adding enduring lockdown it was just
us for a full year
how was quarantine with your children
because for a lot of us it was a real
adventure our kids are four and they
were two and a half when it started so i
didn't have to teach them trigonometry
at
home how is he as a teacher
oh he's great he's mainly teaching
pranks for the time being but we'll see
if it develops well i think those can
really pay off over time
[Music]
you